tu as perdu combien environ tu penses
dans ta vie non alors sincèrement je
pense que je suis je pense que je suis
bénéficiaire
non non c'est pas ok est-ce que je me
suis c'est où non j'ai fait des
mauvaises affaires et c'est exactement
hein c'est mauvaise affaire on les a
jamais compris parce que vous m'écoutez
pas
deux minutes c'est pas qu'on t'écoute
pas c'est quoi Benjamin c'est pas clair
est-ce que tu peux nous dire une fois
pour toutes ces quoi ça voilà alors
troisième perché alors
quand vous achetez un bien ouais ça y
est ça recommence d'accord
en 2003 ok quand
même la musique de
quand 20 ans après que tu as besoin d'un
peu d'oseille tu vends ce bien et que tu
découvres que le bien que tu as acheté
1,8 20 ans avant non mais attends
attends tu l'as acheté cash le main
oui pas tout j'aurais mis parti j'ai mis
un apport tu as mis combien 300 400000
donc prêter un million cinq voilà c'est
bien compter je pensais que vous avez
réussi et au bout de combien d'années
donc là tu as raison après au bout de 20
ans tu l'as remboursé le crédit
écoute-moi
sauf que ton bien 20 ans après il est
vendu aux enchères que tu avais pas être
entre temps 400000 balles ouais donc tu
as perdu donc tu as perdu combien de
millions 45
et en 20 ans normalement n'importe quel
bien de ta chaîne même au trou du cul du
monde un truc tu achètes 10 balles 20
ans après il vaut au moins 15 balles moi
il valait pas 10 balles il valait 2
balles alors je vais me faire chier
longtemps avec mes affaires et tu l'as
acheté où c'est bien
[Rires]
attends
ça d'accord c'est un million 4 mais tu
as gagné beaucoup plus tous les a dit
que tu avais gagné aussi acheter un truc
inexistait pas là ben ça me raconte le
ça il a même épousé des meufs qui
n'existaient pas
et après écoutez que des mecs attends
c'est quoi parce que là d'accord un
million quand même d'accord ok mais
j'avais d'autres choses tu avais quoi
par exemple j'avais acheté un château un
château je croyais que c'est un château
après c'était un tas de pierre mes
frères mais attends mes frères là déjà à
l'époque tu vois des balles donc j'ai
acheté un château par exemple non mais
attends c'est quoi ce soir
il était attends je l'ai encore
d'ailleurs tu as encore ce château de
pierre
et lui il a payé des millions d'euros
c'était vraiment abruti
[Rires]
quel est le gars qui vient de voir qui
dit tiens j'ai un château tu veux pas
l'acheter
le château là et donc toi tu dis ouais
je vais l'acheter combien
tu l'as acheté ce château
qui est la vérité combien je ne sais
plus de dis la vérité à peu près arrête
c'était autre chose
non c'est quoi alors le bail voilà donc
ça bon ça c'est ça en fait j'ai payé des
travaux qu'on l'a jamais fait et en fait
au final j'attends il y a jamais existé
il est tombé en ruine il y a une grosse
mérule vous êtes la mère c'est comme une
chtouille mais c'est dans le mur c'est
un gros champignon
après j'avais acheté des bureaux dans
Paris ouais en fait j'ai des bureaux
dans Paris
non toujours pas
donc ça j'avais acheté des bureaux dans
Paris on avait acheté ça deux millions
deux non ah oui arrête et en fait les
bureaux sont transformés sans que je le
sache en résidence hôtelière
et en fait ça valait pas beaucoup
d'argent et le gars qui m'a vendu ça
j'allais lui faire j'allais lui j'allais
lui le voir pour dire maintenant que tu
vas me rendre mon pognon et on allait
trouver un accord et et le mec il s'est
tué sur l'autoroute le le lendemain et
en fait le gars le gars était un grand
bandit parce que je pense que c'est un
poteau qui a traversé l'autoroute parce
que la voiture elle a quand même pris un
poteau sur l'autoroute aimera et le mec
il est mort j'ai pas pu faire de voilà
donc là j'ai
repéré donc là j'ai donc là ce que
j'avais acheté 2008 là ça va aller en
fait plus rien en fait
tu nous fais rêver
sur ma vie soyez je demande un truc
Arthur je sais que c'est lui qui produit
voilà il veut qu'on peut me faire un
kiffe celui qui produit qui va être mon
associé non mais non il veut pas prendre
ça
et en fait et après moi j'ai fait une
connerie dans ma vie la vraie connerie
que j'ai faite que j'aurais pas dû faire
c'est comme ça c'était des petites
échauffement donc j'avais acheté ces
bureaux à Paris transformés donc ils
sont bien noté sur le sache et le gars
avec qui lui avait fait ça il s'est tué
sur l'autoroute
était un escroc de toi qui s'est barré
en Belgique avec 100 millions d'euros il
a piqué à pas mal de gens dont des
footballeurs d'ailleurs qui sont mêlés
on l'a fait et la dernière chose que
j'avais fait la seule chose que j'avais
fait de bien dans mes placements j'avais
acheté une EHPAD
un des pattes déjà tu sais pas si
Sébastien
donc voilà donc
je travaille pas
et donc là où je me suis tout seul mis
dans le trou c'est quand j'ai commencé à
avoir des problèmes que j'ai voulu
vendre c'est bien de merde qui valait
pas un rond j'ai creusé un découvert qui
était très énorme et j'ai vendu mon
appartement
qui était plutôt pas mal non j'étais
bien que ça je l'ai vendu l'appartement
et j'ai pas remboursé le crédit de la
banque non
et donc tu as gardé l'oseille non pas du
tout j'ai remboursé le découvert
bancaire ouais mais j'ai pas remboursé
d'appartement tout de suite et donc
dites-moi on a fait l'état du cadastre
de l'appartement son petit vous avez
acheté dans le 16e dites-moi il est plus
à vous c'est normal tu commences à faire
donc là vous avez effectivement un
passif qui vient ce qui n'est pas comblé
par un
et là là
après du coup là j'ai perdu la maison de
campagne tout ça les bagnoles et tout
rendu quoi tout tout j'ai vendu les
montres les enfants
et j'ai souvent vendu et je remonte
petit à petit la pente alors là tu la
remonte inch'Allah
on va on va essayer de trouver une
solution mais bon c'est vrai que c'est
mais tout ça pour dire que contrairement
à la télévision la légende urbaine c'est
vrai que dans Paris Samy c'est vrai que
j'ai fait quelques conneries mais j'ai
surtout été pas du tout mais elles
étaient belles hein pas du tout ouais
j'ai pas été prudent et j'ai dû j'ai
fait confiance bêtement
conseil et pour finir j'ai gagné très
bien ma vie pas pendant 10 ou 12 ans 3
ou 4 ans voilà voilà est-ce que je peux
te poser une question
est-ce que tu as un vrai conseil parce
qu'en fait il y a pas pour être honnête
ça tout ça de m'intéressait
pas et en fait voilà je gagne très bien
ma vie je me pensais pas à je pensais
que je passais mon argent correctement
et ça m'intéressait pas et passer des
heures de réunion pour qu'un mec
m'explique que j'allais acheter un
masque j'adore et c'est pour ça que je
quitte voilà donc c'est pour ça que je
l'aime et pour ça que je l'aime je crois
que tous les gens qui gagnent beaucoup
d'argent violemment se trouve quasiment
dans cette situation
de lui tu as vu autour de lui le nombre
de conseils jamais tu t'approches pour
lui demander un peu d'oseille alors j'ai
essayé de faire toi j'ai essayé non mais
j'ai pas réussi mais tu peux pas tu peux
pas il est blindé
partout
même muriel est un conseil en vrai non
non non non mais toi tu dis viens mais
moi ça fait
trois quatre ans
en vrai on s'en rend pas compte
j'ai
quand même
se déroulé ma bosse
30 ans de métier 29 années de galère
c'est incroyable
et ben tu finiras en 94 derrière 94 je
te mets en 2024
ici dans 100 ans si tu verras il y aura
Daniel Moreau